[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here okay so
tesla competition tesla killers
what's the deal it's the end of 2018
right now and this week a fancy new
startup revealed their electric truck
and electric suv called rivien the suv
is a seven passenger called the r1s and
the pickup truck which seems to be the
flagship vehicle is the rivien r1t now
i'm not a pickup truck person by any
means but i am an electric car person
and the specs and the things that they
were promising for this as an electric
vehicle
were actually pretty promising they say
it'll have a huge 180 kilowatt hour
battery bigger than anything on the
market right now it'll have a 400 mile
range it has four motors one at each
wheel which will give it close to 800
horsepower and take it from zero to 60
in three seconds which is fast for any
car but especially for a pickup truck
not that you'd race that thing but hey
that's the benefit of electric
the top speed of 125 miles an hour
fine
and then it can tow up to 11 000 pounds
and go up or down a 45 degree incline
and it has a really advanced suspension
and torque vectoring and all this stuff
so as an electric
truck
it's pretty damn cool if i say so myself
and then obviously since it's the shape
of a pickup truck but minus an engine
and a transmission and all that there
are a ton of space savings and they use
that pretty well there's a huge front
trunk which is awesome for storage space
there's covered storage in the back
there's a full spare there's a flat bed
and then there's also a gear tunnel
through the middle behind the back seats
that can fit large items or backpacks or
whatever you want there's a lot more
storage in there and then beyond that
they just kind of tried to make it a
cool pickup truck the design is a mixed
bag for me i'm not as attracted to the
front and the headlight area but i do
like the back end i think that's cool
but the giant daytime running led
headlights in the front they have a
purpose they are also the charging
indicator
it's a look a pretty solid interior with
some huge screens which might get weird
if it gets dirty if you're getting
rugged with this but i don't mind it i
like less buttons there are wall outlets
in the bed a built-in air compressor a
bed that folds all the way down
cool and it's all coming they say in the
second half of 2020 starting at 69 000.
nice so i asked zach you know him as
jrig everything who is a pickup truck
guy what he thought of this thing these
are his thoughts so i'm a truck guy
trucks can go more places and accomplish
more than cars can and while i'm a huge
fan of my toyota tacoma it's hard to
ignore when an electric truck like the
rivian comes along promising to be
quicker
more powerful and carry more those
features might be too good to be true
but either way i have my pre-order in
and i'm excited to see what happens okay
so this seems like the most promising
electric vehicle that isn't a tesla so
is this the tesla killer
no see the thing is tesla as an electric
car company even with as much as you
read about them in the news and their
problems with ramping up production
with all that
they are
so so so far ahead at making an electric
car a compelling product that people
actually want to buy so here's here's a
couple names for you
faraday future
lucid air these are both the names of
promising new companies with impressive
and compelling electric cars i've done
videos with both of them as i looked for
something to compare to tesla now
they're uh they're kind of both not
doing so hot and they're both definitely
not selling their cars yet so my gut
when this new company rivien comes along
can you blame me it's kind of the same
now to be fair they've existed for a
couple years now behind closed doors in
a sort of a stealth mode and they see
themselves as different they have a
factory space already that they're in
the process of setting up
and they have a couple offices already
it looks like they have a couple design
prototypes and some driving prototypes
and they have this whole snazzy startup
california changing the world video it's
actually really well made but i'll link
it below if you want to watch it but you
can't just skip all the history and all
the money that tesla's put in to get to
where they are in the electric car space
so here's the deal with tesla
competitors i figured i'd put all my
thoughts in one place to make a great
electric car you need a couple things
you need a design a good design
you need a good price
then you'll need great specs
and you'll need
what i'll call convenience and these
pillars are sort of what you need to
compete and they're harder than you
might think design
specs
price and convenience something you've
seen the startups do really well is this
flashy sexy design they do that really
well they don't have any 100 year
history of design heritage they have to
respect they're just kind of an open
book they don't have anything holding
them back they can go futuristic sexy
sporty whatever i love that and then
they can promise really high-end range
and performance and specs on paper
because they're really optimistic
startups so hell yeah we're gonna try to
do zero to sixty in three seconds and
four hundred miles of range on a 180
kilowatt hour battery for sure we can do
that by 2020 totally and they can even
promise to nail the price like i've seen
a couple come out especially recently
where the price tag comes out and people
turn their heads like oh really tesla
killer lucid air which i made a video
with was gonna start their thousand
horsepower electric limo at fifty nine
thousand dollars and riven of course is
coming out now saying they're gonna have
their four motor 180 kilowatt hour
battery pickup starting at 69 000. but
what these startups all lack is the
biggest pillar convenience because
convenience encompasses a couple things
it's
mass production
autonomous driving
and a charging network for me to
conveniently switch to this new car they
need to be making it and selling it in
mass again rivian they say they have a
factory and they're going to start
setting it up but we've all seen how
hard a factory is to set up and
autonomous driving is clearly a massive
convenience and we've seen tesla's been
working on that constantly they just
recently passed a billion miles driven
by teslas with autopilot on that is a
lot of data to learn from and to get
better at it where everyone else
relatively speaking is just starting out
that's software you have to be a whole
software company on top of a car company
to make this part good and then i think
the biggest drawback especially of this
off-road vehicle that people are going
to want to go adventure and drive places
that don't have chargers
is a charging network tesla
supercharging network isn't even
necessary for most people most of the
time if you have a charger in a garage
you just charge up every night to 100
but on the off chance you do go for a
road trip or you do go on an adventure
having a public charging network
wherever you're going and a fast public
charging network is super important and
tesla's built one out like no other for
real nothing is even close and they're
adding to it every month faraday future
lucid air and now rivien
don't use tesla's supercharging network
now to be clear they can tesla's made it
pretty clear that they want people to
actually do that but they choose not to
and for some reason no one's taking them
up on that so with all this convenience
missing and obviously with tesla's
reputation already in the electric car
space being pretty good
uh it makes it tough to see one of these
new startups seem like a big competition
to tesla at least for now so that brings
us to the big dogs the toyotas the bmws
ford mercedes jaguar audi all these
major older car companies with legacy
maybe that's where the tesla killer will
come from major car companies they have
massive manufacturing plants already
they have the staff to dedicate to
making good electric cars they can hire
to get good at software they have the
economies of scale to be competitive
with price they're even already pretty
great at car design and fit and finish
that's one of the big advantages you
have to being a hundred year old company
is you get pretty good at tight
tolerances and making good comfortable
looking and feeling cars inside and out
now i'll excuse some of the first few
attempts at electric cars that i've seen
i really think they got to stop thinking
about electric as this whole new
aesthetic they have to challenge
themselves with that's not really
cutting it but some of them are clearly
starting to get it so that's encouraging
but you know what these huge companies
don't seem to have
ambition they don't seem to want it that
bad and you can see it in the specs and
their promises like the number of car
announcements i see that say they're
going to come out in two to three years
that have a roughly 200 mile max range
is
that's just ridiculous like not only is
that not enough now that's way way too
little in 2020. there's a great video by
ben from the teslanomics channel i'll
link it below that like button where he
goes into much more detail on that point
but it's really good you should watch it
and then on top of all of that they
still don't have the supercharging
network they still don't have the
billion miles of autonomous driving data
to learn from they still don't have the
reputation that tesla has and when it
comes to shopping for electric cars so
tesla killers
i'm still waiting i do think this rivien
truck is probably the most promising and
complete
competitor next to jaguar's i-pace but
they're also more on the horizon from
porsche and audi which are looking very
promising that i'm rooting for i think
tesla needs as much competition as
possible because competition makes us
all better off it makes the products
better and that gives us as consumers a
better selection a more diverse choice
of all these electric cars and trucks
and suvs but by the looks of things
we're still a little ways away from that
there is no tesla killer but we don't
need one there's plenty of room in the
market for competition
and that's what works
thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace